hey guys this is the dean and max with
max tech and today we're gonna show you
how to turn your 2018 iPad pro into a
gaming console so this does not look
like a console what are you talking
about with you so it's technically not a
gaming console but with all the recent
updates coming out and USBC on the iPad
pro we're getting pretty close to people
actually considering this as a console
replacement so iOS gaming is becoming
more and more popular a lot of younger
crowd instead of buying you know an Xbox
or something like that they're gaming on
their phones or their iPads and the
graphics inside of this 11 inch iPad pro
along with the CPU is absolutely insane
so now we have some games like fortnight
that look close to as good as you know
playing it on a PC or an Xbox and with
the iPad pro what really is making this
possible is USB see so now you can use a
cable like this and we'll link this in
the description it's a cheap cable to
plug into a TV or even an 130 inch 4k
projector with surround sound which
we're testing out right here so we're
using the Nimbus 2 controller will leave
a link to it down in the description I
think it's about 40 bucks and it's MFI
certified so you charge it with
lightning and we'll also leave a link to
the cable and some other adapters in the
video description so with this cable you
can't really charge the iPad but with
some of the other adapters you can go
charge and output a video signal at the
same time so let's go ahead and plug
this guy in so we're all plugged in and
you may or may not be able to hear but
we are listening to five point two point
one surround tone or maybe it's the
other way around basically we have to at
most speakers above and yes there's
audio coming from them to front channels
Center Channel and two rear channels and
then a nice subwoofer so this is the
best I've ever heard for tonight the
beautiful thing about the controller
support with Fortnight is you can do
everything with just the controller
going through all the menus literally
everything you can do on Fortnight all
you need is the controller you don't
have to touch the iPad someone's here
get the Martin get the marshmallow there
he is pretty Amon yeah so we do have it
set to 60fps playback
in this case you could just change it to
epic if you don't want 60 if you wanted
at 30 all right so I'm actually going to
go into the settings I'm gonna switch it
to epic instead of high at 60 it can be
epic at 30 frames per second so let's
see how much better the graphics quality
is going to be now that we've switched
over
[Music]
if I get killed by this guy it's hard to
aim someone's over here oh I saw them I
don't expect people to buy an iPad pro
just to do this but if you already have
one because you're using it for other
things then this kind of scenario makes
sense yeah it's nice to have you don't
have to buy another gaming console you
just use this and you're good you see
that it's right in his face what is
going down you through snowman why did
you do that
Oh
[Music]
whoo too late boy
wha-what no let's rap on the ceiling
come on that was the worst gameplay ever
did you guys see that that was
hilariously Ben are you joking me are
you kidding me man can I shoot this guy
from here did you see that snipe the
host insane come on man all right guys
so this was all a big experiment
basically out of curiosity now that we
have us BC we have controller support
can we get a nice experience playing on
the big screen you know any you know big
screen TV 50-inch but in this scenario
130 inch and yes the experience is quite
good so we're looking forward to more
higher end games more controller support
and more Apple devices and other devices
as well with us BC where you just plug
it in like this sit down relax you know
even with you know future cell phones
feature iPhones if you're playing on the
go BAM you plug it in now you got a nice
console like experience so while it may
not replace an Xbox one X or a ps4 pro
or whatever else is going to come out at
least not yet
the power in these iOS devices
especially like the iPad 4 the graphics
and CPU performance is incredible so
this is kind of I guess the future for a
lot of people thank you guys for
watching make sure you guys subscribe
enables notifications if you guys want
to see more videos and we'll see you in
the next one